m
depuis sa plus tendre enfance jean
claude thompson vie au contact de la
nature et des abeilles à ce jour il
possède environ 150 ruches répartis sur
toute l'île le métier d'apiculteur une
passion qui ne le lâche pas un choix qui
s'est imposé comme une évidence et ma
passion de l'apiculture est une eu de
pitié déjà belhaj est beau temps j'avais
j'avais quad quelqu'un 16 ans à l'époque
mais j'aimais les abeilles
bien avant les abeilles que j'aime à
l'époque où j'ai mis les abeilles
c'était à l'a25 on était gamin je voyais
un citronnier bon plein d'abeilles ça ma
télé ça m'attire et je voulais aller
pondre des abeilles il serait temps
qu'un jour mon père m'a fait piquer en
me disant d'aller prendre un grand filet
puis et puis d'attacher les va tâcher
une abeille pour moi et la belle je
devais prendre moi-même je me suis fait
piquer mais ça ne m'a pas fait reculer
et le fait d'aimer la nature c'est à
dire des mé alé d'aller en forêt d'aller
trouver d'aller trouver ses dessins dans
les bois essayez récupérer cssa là et
ben c'est devenu une passion depuis de
nombreuses années le conseil
départemental aide et soutien les
apiculteurs jean claude thompson expose
régulièrement sa production sur les
différents sites de la collectivité lors
de marchés ou manifestations le conseil
général nous a dans des supports des
pieds des subventions
en fonction du nombre de ruches monde
est une bonne chose je remercie à la
présidente je vous dis bien c'est un
heads calcaire qu'elle propose et qui
nous et qui aident à nous faire
connaître
ça c'est quelqu'un qui
revaloriser le métier d'apiculteur
car le fils de jean claude a mis du
temps à s'intéresser aux abeilles ancien
commercial il souhaite désormais mettre
son expérience et ses compétences au
profit de l'entreprise de son père est
alors d'aujourd'hui bon je suis dans
l'optique mon guide et un petit peu mon
pea bon dans les rues ce poste devant
ben il agit d un certain âge et ça
demande beaucoup de temps au tracé dans
les rues
donc moi je viens on pour là dessus non
seulement sur le côté aspect commercial
marketing et ou et puis m'ont apporté un
petit peu la pression très tôt mais
m'investis aussi bon bain dans dans les
rues si l'ambition format bon déjà bon
le concernant et s'est essayé de 2
le promouvoir avons déjà parce que nous
aurons créé son propre produit
mais essayer de proposer un produit de
qualité un produit bon voilà qui va
plaire que les gens va aimer et essayer
de sortir un petit peu bon ok bon de ce
que fait tout le monde l'apiculture
requiert de nombreuses connaissances et
un grand savoir faire
chacun dans leur domaine père et fils
forment désormais une véritable équipe